we spent kind of a lot of time out in
the summer she really did love it down
here
charlotte's mother died at home this
summer not of covid but of cancer
hers was one of thousands of deaths
which have taken place in our homes
a national phenomenon that might well be
changing our relationship with mortality
much has been made of what's happened in
care homes and in hospitals but far
less has been said about something else
something that's been evident in the
data for some time
it's worth just looking at the number of
deaths we've seen versus the average
in various different settings back in
the early weeks of the pandemic i
noticed a striking pattern
what concerns me now is the fact that
actually we're seeing
more deaths at home the number of people
dying at home
was elevated and stayed high even after
lockdown ended
and deaths in other settings dropped
down to normal levels
charlotte's mother was effectively one
of those data points
but her story underlines this is more
complicated and challenging an issue
than anything a chart can tell you the
thing that people need to recognize at
the minute is that
people don't have the option it's it's
very much if you want to spend time with
with your family member then then you're
forced into caring for them at home
and whilst that that may have been the
decision that you come to
in a normal world and you may you know
decide that that's the right thing for
you
in in this life you at this present time
you just don't have
you don't have the choice and i think
when you when you're stripped of that
choice
suddenly you know everything everything
can feel quite overwhelming
looking back on it it was undoubtedly
one of the hard i mean the hardest thing
we've all had to deal with
and you know it being in the house
you know we now have to live in in this
house and it is still home
but there are some quite painful
memories it is one of the rarely told
stories of the pandemic
even what might be described as normal
deaths are happening
differently these days selena who works
in a hospice in devon
has certainly noticed a change there
really isn't a day that goes by now that
we don't have
have a death um because i think where
again they've not accessed
the the support that they've needed and
the people were just dying a lot a lot
quicker because of that
so yeah we're seeing an awful lot of
that a lot of death
the latest figures from the office for
national statistics show that in
domestic settings
excess deaths in other words the number
of people dying above historic levels
are still elevated since march there
have been
28 000 excess deaths at home more than
care homes hospitals
or any other setting but as more have
died at home
their ability to access the support they
need is diminishing
according to a survey of hospices seen
by sky news more than
two-fifths around 44 percent think
they'll have to reduce the volume of
services they can provide
for palliative care and end of life some
93 percent are concerned that people
could miss out on the support
they require it underlines that this is
a story not just about data
office for national statistics say that
there's been 27 and a half
thousand extra deaths at home
since march and uh only two and a half
thousand of those
are covert deaths so there's 25 000 of
these extra deaths have occurred at home
each family
on their own what has been the quality
of those deaths
what has been the end of life care at
home
which is so important there is another
potential explanation about why deaths
at home are so high
and that is that many are suffering
because they are either unable or
unwilling to go into hospitals care
homes or other settings
adrian was due earlier this year to have
a potentially life-saving operation on
his liver
after his bowel cancer spread there but
when the pandemic struck
the operation was cancelled devastated
yeah absolutely devastating we worked so
hard and
kept going with the chemo to get to that
point
only for covid to hit and then it all
changed and
the up got cancelled obviously your
operation is your best
your best chance you've got when you
live in the cancer adrian's cancer is
now
terminal another indirect consequence of
the pandemic
what we are starting to discover in
streets and neighborhoods and households
around the country
is that the nature of normal death is
changing in the face of this pandemic so
deaths that aren't directly or
indirectly caused by covert 19
are still happening differently and
that's something that no single chart
can show you
as britain steals itself for a second
surge of the virus
it is yet another reminder that we're
only beginning to understand the
consequences of this disease
for our lives and our deaths
ed conway sky news